how to save water during California's
water restrictions combined your morning
shower with your morning meeting swap
out your daily cup of coffee
for a cup of oil it's actually not bad
considering how cheap it is brush your
teeth with soda if you're a tech company
replace your indoor plants with a woman
to replace conversations around the
water cooler designate a talking pool
and remember the same if it's yellow let
it Mellow if it's brown go to town find
a clown and ask them to flush it down
can you flush our toilets and if it's
blue see your doctor
to everyone subject an email about email
it seems like everything these days
generates email